during what occasion and during
what thing. We've been through
many chapters regarding this.
What he would say when he is
fasting, what he would say when
he would pray, what he would
say when he'd ride something,
etcetera. Ibn ul Kaim Rahima
Allah says
and yes the
and yes
[Silence]
when a person is out, if they
hear the bray of a donkey, they
are too. Seek refuge in Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
This goes as well for if a
person hears a dog barking at
night A person hears the bark
of a dog at night, They should
seek refuge in Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala from a Shaitan. Say
and that is that in some
narrations, the prophet has
explained to us that a donkey
or a dog at night, if you hear
the bray of a donkey, if you
hear the bark of a dog at
night, this usually articulates
that this creature has seen a
devil, has seen a Shaitan
during the night time. And it's
the opposite with the of a
rooster or a chicken
or the prophet told us that if
we hear the crow of a rooster,
we should seek from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's bounty.
Say, Allah
and the
prophet explained to us
that this articulates that it
probably saw an angel from the
angels of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala that caused it to occur
It's also mentioned in the
sunnah that some narrations
state the prophet
advised that we make if there
is a fire which is out of
control. This narration is
reported but the way that Ibn
ul Kaim Rahima Allah tells us
of this narration. It's kind of
means that the narration is not
authentic and that's the case.
So, if you notice here, he
didn't say the prophet said,
the following. He didn't say
that. He said, it's been
narrated that he said, so why
would a person use that kind of
wording? The reason is, is this
is what is referred to as this
is a way that the scholars of
hadith usually articulate that
a narration is inauthentic or
is questionable in its
authenticity. and so, making
when a fire is out of control,
there are some narrations
encouraging this though their
authenticity is questionable.
Also, the prophet highly
discouraged that a people share
a gathering and that this
gathering be absent of the
remembrance of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Whether that be when
a person begins in their
gathering, that they begin with
the remembrance of Allah or
especially when that gathering
ends, that a people disperse
upon the remembrance of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. He says
[Silence]
this person will receive a
Torah from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala or they are in a state
of here means a state of
as an undesired an undesirable
state to be in from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. If a
person is in a state of from
Allah I mean it translates to
Al Hasra but what's meant here
is that a person who sits in a
gathering does not remember
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
during that gathering. This
individual is in an undesirable
state with Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. He says and whoever
lays down or sits and does not
remember Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala throughout that sitting
will likewise be in a state an
undesirable state from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. He says,
[Silence]
unnecessary things that are
perhaps exaggerations, stuff
that. This is what is
referred to as
that a person speak too much,
talk too much, and probably
kind of go overboard or outside
of a the boundaries of what
they should be speaking about
during that gathering. A person
should end that gathering by
saying
and if they do so, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will
forgive them what has come from
them during this gathering. He
says,
[Silence]
and in
for whatever might occur or
transpire in that gathering
which is undesirable to Allah
Allah. So, it's very good that
whether a person is in a group
or in an individual
conversation with another that
is of some kind of relevance.
We're not speaking about, you
know, every time you just
casually pass someone in the
hall or pass someone in the
masjid and ask em how you're
doing. This is for a midgeless.
A medgeless means that it's a
gathering. We're actually
sitting down, spending,
extensive time together. Then,
in this case whether it's one
person or many people, it is a
good and a good practice that a
person may masjid or
after concluding that
gathering.
Be al Father and
Tukal. this chapter
[Silence]
or he highly discouraged others
say
[Silence]
I have become an evil person. I
have become a terrible person.
This is not something a person
should say about himself.
Rather, a person should pick a
better word to use that is not
so despondent, right? and
another example of this is
referring to grapes as cotton.
Grapes are the source of wine.
And so the pre-Islamic Arabs
would often refer to grapes as
meaning that they are the
source of, they are the source
of generosity Karam and Karam,
they have the same root and
that means that They believed
when a person drank, they start
to feel a little better. They
become more generous and so
sometimes they would actually
drink in order to become more
jealous generous to avoid
feelings of reservation in
giving that they would normally
feel if they were sober. and so
They would refer to the source
of wine as generosity, the
source of generosity. Cuddle.
kind of an hour lingo we
refer to alcohol as courage. We
call it liquid courage, right?
Cuz when a person drinks, they
become more courageous.
Likewise, they would kind of
refer to it as generosity, kind
of liquid generosity. But
the prophet prohibited this and
he said, the source of
generosity is really the heart
of the believer.
He said
Another thing the prophet
prohibited discourage that
people say And again it's not
just the wording but also the
meaning that these words
contain.
being in everybody is doomed.
Everybody is as you know the
world is falling apart. People,
there's no more hope in them.
There's no more good in people.
People are doomed, right? This
kind of pessimistic outlook is
something the prophet
prohibited and he said, whoever
has this kind of outlook or
says such a thing, then, they
are one of the cause of
people's
people's negative outcome And
in another wording, Fahu
meaning he is the most doomed
of all of them. The one who
says and sees things this.
He also prohibited that a
person say things like
that. That Such and such star
such and such star has become
the cause of rain on earth. You
know, they, this is going back
to astrology. In the time of
the companions, still till
today, but many ancient
civilizations and so forth,
they would have superstitious
beliefs regarding the stars and
the movement of the stars and
the celestial bodies above
them. And so, they would notice
a particular star would come,
you know, have the same kind of
thing and kind of European
mythology that certain stars
were actually certain gods that
would control things on earth.
There were a lot of beliefs
that were this. I'm not
sure exactly what the belief of
the polytheist of the prophet
time was with regards to this
particular star but they had
certain stars that they marked
kind of in their mind. That's
when this star would appear or
move a particular way, it would
always rain when that would
happen. So, whenever it would
rain, they would say, such and
such star has caused it to
rain. This of course is
something which is
impermissible. And
superstitions such as these,
whether it be whether it be
belief that these stars have
some kind of influence on the
Earth by Allah Subhanahu wa
ta'ala or independent
influence. Of course, both is
considered to be a type of
shirk. One more egregious than
the other. This is all part of
astrology. And astrology is
strictly prohibited in Islam.
Belief in it is considered to
be superstition. And one of the
many branches of a very larger
thing which is referred to in
the Quran as magic or sorcery.
So the prophet tells us
Adam has said, he says
whoever
[Silence]
which is strictly prohibit in
Islam. Clearly in the Quran,
clearly in the prophet
and kind of off off topic a
little bit. We're expanding the
topic a little bit. These
things are prohibited in any
form that they're in. So, for
instance, the horoscope is a
type of is a type of astrology.
It's a practice of astrology.
It's all superstition. When a
person looks at his or her
horoscope, what month you're
born in? And what effect this
has on your month Such and such
is going to happen today or
this week or this month or
you're going to have this kind
of year if you were born in
this month, right? All of these
things are part of astrology.
This is all goes back to a
person claiming or laying claim
to knowledge of the future and
noone has any knowledge of the
future except by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Memphis
Allah says say that none, noone
knows what is to come or the
future except for Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta
and so, this
It's all a branch of astrology
There's a very popular book in
America that we've had for,
gosh, probably over 100 years,
probably almost 200 years. It's
called the Farmers Almanac and
you can still go into certain
stores and find them sold by
the register. This farmer's
almanac before the age of
satellite monitoring of weather
patterns and so forth. People
were extremely people were
extremely superstitious with
regards to when it's going to
rain, what kind of frost is
going to come because you know,
people would have a farm and
any unexpected frost or any
early frost or late such and
such might affect their crops,
might kill their crops, might
affect their yield. And so
people were very superstitious
and this farmer's farmer's
almanac was printed and
published and is still printed
and published till today. and
it would speak about things
that are going to happen in the
year to come and based on the
movement of the stars this this
day is going to be this
and this week is going to be
this and there's going to
be a late summer or an early
winter or any of these things
that affect them. This of
course is all superstition.
This of course is all nonsense
and very impermissible for a
person to read, let alone for a
person to believe.
Another thing that the prophet
prohibited is that when a
person swear that they swear by
other than Allah. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala. A lovely year. Neha and
yeah
Danny, the
[Silence]
Things that are creations of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This
is infamous. Person swears.
They swear only by Allah. I
swear by Allah or an attribute
of Allah's attributes is
permissible. But the essence of
how the prophet would add
exclamation or add emphasis to
his statements. Is that he
would swear by Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. not necessarily by
the attribute of Allah. He
would swear by Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. There is a narration
in which the prophet tells us
whoever is to swear, then he is
to swear by Allah or remain
silent.
He is to swear by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala or remain
silent.
Sultan
Malik Al
[Silence]
Many times, they'll swear by
certain things or pray that
certain things happen if they
are, if they are untruthful for
instance. So, say things like
you know, may Allah strike him
down as a you know, speaking
about himself. As a if I'm not
saying the truth, right? Or I
am not Muslim if such and such
is the case. you know, my my
children be swept away and such
and such or may they die if I'm
being untruthful. These kinds
of statements are totally
unnecessary. If a person wishes
to emphasize the veracity of
his statement, he should say, I
swear by Allah, such and such.
Wallahi, such and such, that's
enough. Not increase that, not
go beyond that. This is
something which impermissible.
Impermissible for a person and
sometimes people are kind of
overly dramatic in certain
things. They're in a dispute or
if they're having a dispute
with someone, they make these
very grand grandiose statements
and this is something which is
unnecessary. If a person wishes
to swear, by anything which is
emphasize what he's saying
swear by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala or don't swear at all by
anything. Also wishing things
upon a person's self such as
death or dying upon other than
Islam or death for others
etcetera. This is something
which is impermissible. Another
thing the prophet prohibited
and highly discouraged in
that which we say is that a
person referred to any king as
the king of kings. This is the
title reserved only for Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. is also
prohibited on the other side
that an owner, if a person, for
instance, owns a slave, that he
say, my slave, refer to the
person as my slave. and the
reason for that is that these
statements are outwardly
grandiose and outwardly these
statements are titles that
belong only to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and references only
made between Allah and his
servants. So, it is Allah who
says, my servants, my slaves,
rather than a person, say, my
slave, because this articulates
a grandiosity, a grandeur that
is only the strict domain of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Likewise, the king of kings.
This is strictly a title for
Allah. The judge of Judges,
this is strictly a title for
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Another thing the prophet has
prohibited is cursing the wind.
that a person cursed the wind,
say, and we say this often and
there's this is something that
is very common in people's
words. Say, dam, wind, damn the
wind, things that or
anything the wind. Time,
day,
night. These are things
which are impermissible for a
person to
curse is essentially for a
person to damn something.
That a person curse or damn
fever or damn a rooster or the
crow of a rooster. Well,
[Silence]
kind of tribalist or something
that is considered to be
nationalist or racist. Any of
these calls, any of these
affiliations. What affiliates
us is solely our lineage, our
tribe, solely our origins or
our race and to exclude others
and to kind of make an
offensive between this and
everyone else, us and the rest
of everyone. This is all
considered to be of this is all
considered to be of the calls
of Jehilia and the unities of
Jehilia. What joins us is what
joins us is the worship of
Allah. Subhanahu wa ta'ala
alone without any partners. And
that is the only thing that
causes or triggers in us a
level of what and that we align
ourselves with those who align
themselves with this and we
consider ourselves different
and differentiate ourselves,
and distinguish ourselves from
those who oppose Allah. This is
the basis of our as for
nationalism or racism or
tribalism or any of these
things. This is something which
is obviously impermissible
we'll continue on that note
next week.
[Arabic recitation]